et henri sterdyniak économiste au centre
de recherche en économie de sciences po
et membres des économistes atterrés nous
a rejoint sur ce plateau henri
sterdyniak bonjour bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors la cgt
qui claquent la porte de la conférence
de financement c'était prévisible
disons que cette conférence de
financement n'avait pas grand sens pour
la sage la cgt puisque le gouvernement
l'avait organisé avec que le diktat qu'
il fallait absolument que les
partenaires sociaux se trouvent se
mettre d'accord pour récupérer 1 12
milliard en 2017 à 2027 l'évaluation que
le gouvernement faisait du déficit
prévisible dans la mesure où la cgt
estime que ce déficit prévisible
n'existe pas dans la mesure où la cgt
n'est pas prêt à prendre des mesures a
préconisé des mesures pour réduire les
retraites pour retarder l'âge de départ
à la retraite pour économiser ses 12
milliards effectivement la cgt avait pas
grand chose à faire dans cette
conférence
est ce que dans ce contexte là d'autres
syndicats pourraient quitter cette
conférence je pense notamment à la cfdt
pour qui cette conférence de financement
a été accordé en partie il faut voir
quels seront les suggestions que va
faire la cfdt et comment le gouvernement
va les recevoir
jusqu'à présent le gouvernement est
ferme sur une position
trouvez-moi 12 milliards et trouver
moins 12 milliards sans augmenter les
cotisations et trouvez-moi 12 milliards
sont sans baisser les pensions est la
seule solution que voit le gouvernement
c'est retarder l'âge de départ à la
retraite maintenant la cfdt peut avoir
d'autres propositions il pourrait y en
avoir d'autres pourra y en avoir
d'autres par exemple en 2025 on a
remboursé la dette sociale donc ça veut
dire que en 2024
on va rembourser 24 milliards aux
marchés financiers et par on peut dire
ben l'année suivante c'est 24 milliards
ils vont servir
à combler le déficit éventuel des
retraites
et même il en reste un petit bout pour
financer la dépendance
et par ailleurs il ya une grande partie
de ce déficit qui est dû au fait que le
gouvernement annonce qu'il va baisser le
nombre de fonctionnaires qui va pas
augmenter
'l'indice de traitements de la fonction
publique gaillac à dire au gouvernement
renoncé à baisser le nombre de
fonctionnaires on peut facilement
augmenter le nombre de fonctionnaires
dans les hôpitaux ou à la police ou à la
justice
indexé correctement 'l'indice du point
de la fonction publique il y aura pas de
déficit mais dont une telle proposition
pourrait être acceptée par le
gouvernement formulée comme vous venez
de le faire non pas bien sûr que dans
parce que foncièrement le but du
gouvernement c'est pas de notre allié le
déficit
imaginez le but du gouvernement
foncièrement c'est de baisser le poids
des retraites dans le pib le coût
le gouvernement sait qu'il va y avoir
25% de retraités en plus et il présente
un projet de loi dans lequel il dit
la part des retraites dans le pipe va
baisser de 13,8 à 12.9 il va falloir
d'une façon ou d'une autre réduire le
montant des retraites et il va falloir
retarder l'âge de départ à la retraite
et le gouvernement ne veut pas céder sur
ces deux points et donc ensuite on
demande aux partenaires sociaux de de
bavarder et foncièrement le gouvernement
ne change pas ses deux objectifs donc au
fond cette conférence de financement sa
simple bavardage comme vous venez de le
dire
oui c'est un bavardage et puis c'est un
avantage c'est que les résultats
couronnent le gouvernement a déposé un
projet de loi avec un article 57 qui
nous dit le l'article 57 va dépendre des
résultats de la conférence de
financement et donc ça permet au
gouvernement de gagner du temps on ne
sait pas si oui ou non dans le projet de
loi y aura l'idée de douar philippe sur
lequel il va falloir travailler jusqu'à
64 ans dès 2000 27 pour avoir une
retraite au taux plein et on le saura
que
dans trois mois une fois que les députés
auront voté une première fois la loi
on va rajouter un article supplémentaire
c'est du point de vue de la démocratie
parlementaire c'est quand même tout à
fait extravagants il nous reste très peu
de temps mais peut-être pour conclure on
a entendu cette rumeur du 49-3 qui plane
de plus en plus dans les couloirs de
l'assemblée nationale
quel est votre regard justement sur
cette méthode si elle devait être
appliquée je pense que compte tenu de le
gouvernement ne veut pas céder le
gouvernement a une majorité tout à fait
garanti à l'assemblée nationale donc
l'opposition a choisi une méthode
d'obstruction et donc il ya un blocage
total de gouvernement va en sortir par
le 49-3 qui horrible puisque ça veut
dire que il va imposer ses vues et qu'il
y aura aucun moyen pour les différentes
professions concernées d'aménager le
texte par l'intermédiaire d'amendements
raisonnable qui aurait pu être porté par
les députés et donc c'est disons
l'obstination qui du gouvernement est
également la riposte choisi par france a
soumis ce qu'ils vont aboutir à la
situation le pire la pire c'est-à-dire
un texte mal pensée mal conçu qui va
passer sans examen parlementaire
merci beaucoup henri sterdyniak d'avoir
partager votre avis sur notre plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes économiste au
centre de recherche en économie de
sciences po est également membre des
économistes à terre merci